[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Gundula
Gause und Dunja Hayali
[Musik]
schönen guten Abend jetzt also doch
Wirtschaftsminister Harbeck entlässt
seinen Staatssekretär Patrick reichen
für viele war dieser Schritt längst
überfällig für Robert Habeck zunächst
nicht seit drei Wochen seit den ersten
Medienberichten über die Fehler reichens
in Bezug auf die Besetzung eines Postens
standhabek hinter ihm doch nun wurde
noch weitere gravierende Verflechtungen
bekannt damit war der Mann der ja als
Architekt der Grünen Klimaschutzpolitik
gilt nicht mehr zu halten ob aus
Einsicht oder wegen des öffentlichen
Drucks die Entlassung in den vorzeitigen
Ruhestand folgte heute denn die
Glaubwürdigkeit war ja massiv beschädigt
die des Staatssekretärs ob auch die des
Ministers werden wir gleich besprechen
zuvor Karl Hinterleitner mit den
Hintergründen
ganz am Schluss schafft es Robert Habeck
sogar noch einen Witz zu machen auf die
Frage wer Nachfolger von Patrick reichen
wird eine Antwort halb im Spaß halb
sarkastisch ziemlich gequält also ich
würde ihn nicht mehr ein Trauzeugen
jetzt als Staatssekretär berufen
was vorausgegangen war alles andere als
lustig für den Bundeswirtschaftsminister
sichtlich angefasst hatte habe ich
verkünden müssen was nicht mehr zu
verhindern war es ist der eine Fehler zu
viel
deshalb habe ich heute diese
Entscheidung getroffen es ist eine
weitreichende
schwere Entscheidung weitreichend für
mein Haus schwer für mich und sehr hart
für Patrick reichen der steht seit
Wochen im Sturm der Kritik am Anfang
standen Vorwürfe der Vetternwirtschaft
reichen wollte seinen Trauzeugen Michael
Schäfer zum neuen Chef der Deutschen
Energieagentur machen und jetzt auch
noch das reichen befürwortete eine
finanzielle Förderung für den
Naturschutzverband Bund seine Schwester
sitzt dort im Vorstand die Fehler sind
unterschiedlich gravierend und stünde
jeder dieser Fehler für sich allein
würde er eine solch dramatische
Konsequenz wie wir sie heute ziehen
nicht nötig machen
aber die Fehler stehen eben nicht für
sich allein der Bundeskanzler äußerte
sich heute vom europaratgipfel für die
zukünftige Regierungsarbeit sieht er
keine Probleme mit Herrn reichen selbst
habe ich gut zusammengearbeitet und ich
gehe davon aus dass der
Wirtschaftsminister jetzt seine Arbeit
mit voller Kraft fortsetzt das sieht die
Opposition völlig anders das Problem sei
keineswegs erledigt es brauchen mehr
Transparenz und es komme darauf an ob
Habeck jetzt seine Politik noch umsetzen
kann mit der Auswechslung von Staat Herr
kreischen ist die Vertrauenskrise die
sich hier aufgetan hat nicht erledigt
wir brauchen Auskünfte darüber welche
Konsequenzen werden jetzt gezogen damit
in Zukunft Brandmauern tatsächlich
halten ich messe natürlich auch daran
was jetzt aus dem politischen Vorhaben
wird und er ist gefordert die
Energiewende umzusetzen die wärmewende
umzusetzen und zwar so dass sie
ökologisch nachhaltig und sozial gerecht
das schlimm auch aus den eigenen Reihen
kommt Kritik den Koalitionspartner FDP
geht es um das wofür Habeck und gleich
entstehen das umstrittene heizungsgesetz
uns als Parlament fehlt jetzt ein
Ansprechpartner für dieses
heizungsgesetz und deswegen meine ich
Herr Harbeck wäre gut darin beraten
jetzt einen neuen Zeitplan für dieses
heizungsgesetz vorzulegen und damit auch
deutlich zu machen dass er ein
heizungsgesetz möchte das oft auf der
Basis des Koalitionsvertrags steht Fazit
es war eine überfällige Entlassung mit
der habe ich aber seinen wichtigsten
Mann verliert damit steht jetzt auch das
Gelingen seiner Energiewende auf dem
Spiel
wir haben natürlich Robert Habeck die
Spitze der Grünen und einige mehr
angefragten die man wollte bzw konnte
jetzt muss der Generalsekretär der SPD
die Kohlen für seinen Koalitionspartner
quasi aus dem Feuer holen und damit
einen schönen guten Abend Kevin Kühnert
nach Berlin guten Abend Frau ali ist der
Rauswurf richtig
ja der Rauswurf ist richtig und am Ende
auch unvermeidlich gewesen gerade nach
dem was Robert Habeck in seinem
Präsident heute zu den jüngsten
Erkenntnissen des Ministeriums selbst
noch einmal gesagt hat er war notwendig
um Vertrauen wiederherstellen zu können
in die Handlung des Ministeriums aber
auch der Bundesregierung insgesamt und
das ist auch der Grund weshalb ich hier
heute Rede und Antwort stehe wer für uns
ein leichtes uns in die Bücher zu
schlagen zusammen betrifft andere aber
die SPD trägt Gesamtverantwortung für
diese Regierung und deswegen ist es auch
unsere mitaufgabe den Menschen zu
erklären was gerade passiert in der
Regierung aber müsste dann nicht Robert
habe auch zurücktreten denn das fällt ja
auch auf ihn zurück es geht hier wie sie
gerade gesagt haben um Glaubwürdigkeit
Vertrauen und nicht um expertise
geht darum dass nicht mal der Anschein
bei politischen Handeln entstehen darf
dass irgendeine persönliche Verbindung
etwas was der Volksmund vielleicht
Günstlingswirtschaft oder ähnliches
nennen würde dass das eine Rolle spielt
um es klar zu sagen nach allem was ich
über Patrick reichen den ich persönlich
nicht gut kenne weiß es ist ein
hochkompetenter Kundiger Mann dem ich
persönlich nichts Böses unterstelle aber
das eben auch nur der Eindruck
entstanden ist da könnte etwas
gemauschelt worden sein geht nicht und
deswegen war es richtig dass Robert
Habeck diese Konsequenz gezogen hat und
dafür sollen wir ihm auch Respekt und
das ist die richtige Entscheidung nicht
auch zurücktreten müsste denn es fällt
ja auf ihn als Minister zurück er trägt
Verantwortung für seinen Ministerium
das ist richtig aber auch
Staatssekretäre gehören zur politischen
Spitze eines Ministeriums dazu und es
ist für einen Minister für jeden
Minister auch für Robert habe keine
einfache Entscheidung jemand so engen
Vertrauten wie ein Staatssekretär zu
entlassen diese Entscheidung hat er
heute getroffen und das ist eben auch
ein klares Zeichen nach außen dass man
sich dann nicht durch wurschtelt sondern
dass man auch einen Strich zieht der
noch mal notwendig gewesen ist auch der
Kanzler hat sich heute zu dem Rücktritt
geäußert und hat gesagt ich gehe davon
aus dass der Wirtschaftsminister jetzt
seine Arbeit mit voller Kraft fortsetzt
ich gehe davon ausklingen nicht so als
würde er ihm komplett den Rücken stärken
ich glaube schon dass er eben damit klar
den Rücken gestärkt hat denn wir
brauchen auch einen funktionierendes
Bundesministerium für Wirtschaft und
Klima denn das ist ja ein Themenbereich
in dem wir uns große Vorhaben gesetzt
haben in der Ampelkoalition und wir
haben ja auch alle miteinander in den
letzten Tagen und Wochen gemerkt dass
die großen Diskussionen über Themen der
wärmewende beispielsweise dass diese
Fragen zunehmend von einer
sachpolitischen Diskussion zu einer
personalpolitischen Diskussion geworden
sind ich möchte damit nicht sein dass
man nicht über Patrick reichen
diskutieren durfte ganz im Gegenteil
dafür gab es Anlass dafür hat er Anlass
gegeben aber man kann sich nicht der
sachlichen Auseinandersetzung über das
Wie der wärmewende entziehen indem man
die Person alleine in den Mittelpunkt
stellt und glaubt damit sei schon alles
gesagt so hat es die Union in den
letzten Wochen versucht sie wollen den
Inhalt wieder in den Fokus rücken und da
gibt es jetzt heute stimmen auch aus der
Koalition konkrete FDP die sagen wenn
reichen ja so wichtig war so klang ist
ja immer auch wie Rob ert Habeck ist
dann formuliert hat dann kann das
Gebäude Energiegesetz jetzt nicht kommen
stimmen Sie dem Zug braucht das jetzt
mehr Zeit dafür
ich finde beide Sachverhalte haben
nichts miteinander zu tun wir haben auf
der einen Seite Patrick reichen der
heute von Robert Habeck aus seinem Amt
entlassen wurde wegen persönlicher
Verfehlungen weil wie man vielleicht
norddeutsch sagen würde Compliance
Fragen im Umgang mit dem Ministerium mit
Mittelvergabe nicht eingehalten wurden
auf der anderen Seite diskutieren wir in
Deutschland seit Wochen das sogenannte
Gebäude Energiegesetz das was auch als
heizungsgesetz bekannt ist das zentrale
Gesetz wenn es darum geht wie unser
Gebäude Sektor der für 30% der
Emissionen in Deutschland verantwortlich
ist in den nächsten 22 Jahren
klimaneutral werden soll ich sehe nicht
was es sachlich miteinander zu tun hat
dass der Abgang von Patrick reichen
jetzt dazu führen soll dass wir kein
Gebäude Energiegesetz mehr machen um es
klar zu sagen es gibt keine
Klimaneutralität in Deutschland ohne
dass wir an unserer Art zu heizen
rangehen an dieser Notwendigkeit hat
sich mit dem heutigen Tag nichts aber
auch gar nichts geändert jetzt hat sich
einiges für Robert Habeck in seinem
Ministerium geändert und man fragt sich
von außen schon wenn man sieht Werder
mit wem und so weiter gibt es denn
eigentlich keine guten Experten oder
Experten die mehr oder weniger nicht
alle aus dieser gleichen Ecke kommen
also ich kenne jetzt nicht alle Akteure
in der Landschaft aber ich kenne genug
um zu wissen da gibt es ganz viele die
seit vielen Jahren an der Energiewende
in Deutschland Europa und der Welt
arbeiten die große Expertise haben und
ja die hat man sich dann eben häufig
auch in Vorfeld und Umfeld
Organisationen ehrenamtlichen
Zusammenhängen
ran geschafft und spricht auch überhaupt
gar nichts dagegen dass sich die
Beschäftigten dort auf Konferenzen und
Kongressen schon einmal getroffen haben
dass die auch im persönlichen Austausch
miteinander sind es muss nur allen die
in einer Regierung und in Behörden in
verantwortlicher Stelle Arbeiten zu
jeder Zeit klar sein dann wenn es um die
Vergabe von Jobs oder die Vergabe
öffentlicher Mittel das Steuergeld der
deutschen geht dann darf auch nur der
anscheinend dass da einen
Freundschaftsdienst erledigt wird nicht
entstehen und deswegen darf es
eigentlich im Nachhinein einfallen wenn
ein Bewerber für einen wichtigen Job der
eigene Trauzeuge gewesen ist oder dass
eine begüterte
Verbände Struktur von der eigenen
Schwester geleitet wird das hätte nicht
vorkommen dürfen und deswegen hat das
jetzt zurecht auch Konsequenzen nach
sich gezogen die Compliance Regeln
wurden viel gepriesen haben aber nicht
funktioniert Kevin Kühnert war das der
Generalsekretär der SPD vielen
herzlichen Dank für Ihre Zeit ich danke
Ihnen
und das Gespräch haben wir vor einer
knappen halben Stunde aus Termin Gründen
aufgezeichnet und dann noch gerne ein
Hinweis denn heute auch im heute journal
Update wird dieses Thema weiter vertieft
dort ist dann Anna Maja Mertens die
Geschäftsführerin von Transparency
International Deutschland zu Gast
gestern hatten wir hier schon über die
Absicht des Europarates in Bezug auf ein
Ukraine schadensregister berichtet und
heute Gundula Vollzug der Europarat hat
ein schadensregister für die
Zerstörungen in der Ukraine beschlossen
es ist ein Signal an Moskau das Russland
zur Rechenschaft gezogen werden soll und
ein Zeichen der Solidarität mit Kiew mit
dem schadensregister sollen alle von
Russland angerichteten Zerstörungen in
der Ukraine dokumentiert werden auch um
Entschädigungszahlungen an die Ukraine
zu ermöglichen sechs Mitglieder tragen
das schadensregister allerdings nicht
mit darunter die Türkei
Russland und die Ukraine haben sich auf
eine Verlängerung des getreideabkommens
verständigt es gelte für weitere zwei
Monate teilte der türkische Präsident
Erdogan mit so können auch weiterhin
Frachter ukrainisches Getreide über das
Schwarze Meer nach Istanbul liefern
ursprünglich sollte das Abkommen morgen
Auslaufen vor allem Afrika ist auf
Getreidelieferungen aus der Ukraine
angewiesen
da auch Afrika unter dem Krieg leidet
haben sechs Länder des Kontinents eine
Friedensinitiative angekündigt
Südafrikas Präsident Rama Posa erklärte
er werde gemeinsam mit fünf anderen
afrikanischen Regierungschefs sobald wie
möglich nach Moskau und Kiew reisen die
Präsidenten Putin und selenski hätten
jeweils zugestimmt
weder Großbritannien noch Deutschland
werden der Ukraine auf absehbare Zeit
Kampfjets liefern das machten die
Verteidigungsminister Wallace und
Pistorius in Berlin deutlich
Großbritannien wolle ukrainische
pilotenausbilden bestätigte Wales habe
aber die von Kiew geforderten Kampfjets
nicht auch die Bundeswehr habe hier
weder Kapazitäten noch Kompetenzen sagte
Pistorius
die russische Armee setzt die Angriffe
vor allem im Osten und Süden der Ukraine
fort Militärexperten vermuten dass sich
das russische Militär bei bachmut
verstärkt und umgruppiert um eine
Einkesselung durch ukrainische
Streitkräfte zu verhindern
am Oberlandesgericht Koblenz hat der
Prozess gegen fünf mutmaßliche
Mitglieder der sogenannten reichsbrücker
Szene begonnen der Anklage zur Folge
wollten die sogenannten vereinten
Patrioten
bürgerkriegsähnliche Zustände auslösen
sie sollen den Sturz der Regierung
geplant haben sowie die Entführung von
Gesundheitsminister Lauterbach ein
Urteil wird erst im Januar erwartet
wer sexualisierte Gewalt erlebt hat
trägt diese Spuren für den Rest seines
Lebens in sich der ein oder die andere
verkraftete Tat wie Aufarbeitung sicher
unterschiedlich schmerzhaft bis
zerstörend sind solche Übergriffe
allemal erst recht wenn man sie als Kind
erfahren musste wie bitter muss es aber
erst sein wenn diese Taten von
Schutzbefohlenen ausgegangen sind und
dann selbst nach Aufdeckung eine
Institution noch immer die schützende
Hand über die Täter hält nicht Gottes
Hand sondern die der Kirche so geht es
ja unzähligen Opfern in der katholischen
Kirche die in den Augen vieler
Betroffener immer noch zu wenig tut 9
von ihnen sind deshalb nach oben
gepilgert auf Fahrrädern mit einem Brief
dem sich selbst der Papst nicht
entziehen konnte Barbara Luke und Jutta
sonnewald
okay
Zeit für den großen Moment
Papst franziskus kommt Privataudienz für
Missbrauchsopfer aus Bayern sie schenken
ihm symbolisch ein verletztes Herz und
unverhohlene Botschaften wir Betroffenen
haben kein rotes Herz mit einem Pfeil
wir haben ein fragiles Herz und helfen
Sie mit dass die Priester nicht vor uns
davonlaufen der Vater ist ab wie die
anderen alle Missbrauch erlebt bin
trotzdem Priester geworden Kilian semel
überreicht einen Brief mit der Forderung
Täter der Kirche zu bestrafen und
Missbrauch weltweit zu unterbinden das
hat Priorität sagt der Papst
es ist das Ende einer denkwürdigen Reise
zehn Tage radeln Frauen und Männer die
als Kinder von Priestern sexuell
missbraucht wurden von München über die
Alpen nach Rom es ist eine Pilgerfahrt
voller Begegnungen Tränen Konfrontation
und der Suche nach Gemeinschaft und
Gespräch mit Bürgern Fahrern und
Bischöfen
einige Betroffene zeigen zum ersten Mal
ihr Gesicht
Problem dass sie ja das jahrzehntelang
reingefressen habe und
bis zum totalen Zusammenbruch halt mit
schwerer Depression und Kliniker
Aufenthalt in der geschlossenen
Abteilung der Psychiatrie
Missbrauch endlich aufzuklären Tabus zu
brechen Vertuschung zu bekämpfen das ist
die Mission ihrer Pilgerfahrt und sie
spüren Rückenwind wir leben jetzt gerade
dass sich unglaublich viele Menschen mit
uns kommen aufzustehen zu sprechen sich
zu orten vielleicht auch an die
Öffentlichkeit zu gehen und dadurch wird
passieren dass Kirche sich bewegt
Richard Kick wurde als Ministrant von
einem Priester schwer missbraucht lange
wurde der Fall ignoriert und verschleppt
Kik brach Schule und Ausbildung ab litt
unter Alkoholismus
Treffen mit dem Münchner kardinalmarkt
kik hat vor allem mit ihm gefochten um
Anerkennung um Entschädigung Jahre lang
bei der gemeinsamen Andacht aber brechen
an diesem Tag alle Dämme
Österreich
es ist ein Augenblick voller Empathie
doch wie nachhaltig sind Momente wie
dieser und wird der Papst wirklich
handeln
Kilian semel jedenfalls der es als
Priester besser machen will ist tief
berührt an diesem Tag ich weiß nicht nur
einfach ein Akt sondern es war ja es war
im Moment tiefer tiefer Herzlichkeit im
wahrsten Sinne des Wortes und verbindet
das Herz
es klingt fast wie eine Mahnung denn
diese Betroffenen werden nicht mehr
locker lassen
wenn wir nach Afghanistan schauen dann
geht es ja häufig um Anschläge die
Taliban die Unterdrückung von Frauen
oder die Verschlechterung der
Menschenrechtslage insgesamt selten wird
darüber berichtet dass Afghanistan eines
der Länder ist das weltweit am stärksten
von den Folgen des Klimawandels
betroffen ist und der hat dort jetzt
schon fatale Auswirkungen durch
Überschwemmungen und Dürre wird zum
Beispiel die Ernte und damit auch die
Lebensgrundlage der Menschen zerstört da
wirkt das Projekt das Katrin Eigendorf
für uns in der Nähe von Kabul besucht
hat wie der Tropfen auf dem heißen Stein
ausgetrocknete Flussbetten kargehügel in
wagrami einem Distrikt 15 km östlich von
Kabul sind die Folgen des Klimawandels
unübersehbar mit einem Staudamm soll die
Zukunft der umliegenden Dörfer gesichert
werden Philippe Kropf Sprecher des
un-welternährungsprogramms lässt sich
von den afghanischen Ingenieuren die
Baustelle zeigen ein Kanal in dem das
Wasser aus dem China Fluss in die Felder
gelenkt werden soll der gleichzeitig
auch Schutz bei Überflutungen bildet
wenn wir das Anschauen wir sind 20 30
Klima Notstand 5 Millionen afghanien
Afghanen werden vertrieben werden bis
2030 die sind entweder Binnenflüchtlinge
oder Flüchtlinge in anderen Ländern
Nachbarländer vielleicht auch nach
Europa das ist können wir hier mit
solchen Projekten helfen zu verhindern
und insofern wäre das natürlich die
Hoffnung dass das die Zukunft wird
Frauen sind auf der Baustelle nicht zu
sehen nur die Dorfältesten überzeugen
als zum ersten Mal Wasser in den Kanal
läuft
2200 Hektar Land sollen durch die
Bewässerung fruchtbar gemacht werden und
35.000 Menschen die Ernährung sichern
chiwaki ist eines der Dörfer das von den
Entwicklungen profitiert während wir
durch die Straßen gehen werden wir
neugierig beäugt wegen der schlechten
Sicherheitslage haben Ausländer die
Region lange gemieden doch nun wachen
die Taliban über die Arbeit der
Entwicklungshelfer und diktieren auch
die Bedingungen seitdem sie verfügt
haben dass Frauen nur noch in
Krankenhäusern und Schulen arbeiten
dürfen haben zahlreiche internationale
Organisationen ihre Arbeit eingestellt
in chiwaki ist es dem
Welternährungsprogramm gelungen sie
einzubeziehen fachhunde die sich auf der
Straße nur in Burka zeigt nimmt uns mit
zu ihrem Haus und zeigt uns was Sie von
einer Ausbilderin des
Welternährungsprogramms gelernt hat wie
man effektiv Gemüse und Obstpflanzen
kann küchengärten nennt sich das Projekt
wir haben alles angepflanzt und
kultiviert jetzt kann ich das Verkaufen
das macht mich glücklich ich habe kleine
Kinder die möchte ich zur Schule
schicken wenn ich nicht das Geld hätte
sie zu unterstützen wäre das
unerträglich
zu eV Verschwörer die seit vielen Jahren
schon in Afghanistan arbeitet ist das
Projekt ein Lichtblick in einer
schwierigen Zeit
für ihre Kinder kaufen Sachen für sich
selber kaufen
da hatte man schon das Gefühl jetzt eben
auch das haben sie auch selbst gesagt
dass sie das nachträglich verändert hat
und ich denke schon dass wir die auch
gesehen haben dass es ihnen auch mehr
Selbstbewusstsein gegeben hat ohne
Frauen das wird in bakrami deutlich ist
Entwicklungshilfe in Afghanistan nicht
ernsthaft machbar an die Lämmer dass ich
nicht einfach lösen lässt
und damit zurück nach Deutschland und da
gab es heute quasi 30 auf einen Schlag
Gundula was hat es denn damit auf sich
an diesem Mittwoch haben 30
Aktienunternehmen ihre
Hauptversammlungen abgehalten die
wenigsten von ihnen riefen ihre
Eigentümer persönlich zusammen die
meisten Hauptversammlungen sind virtuell
auch die der Deutschen Bank heute Frank
beetmann warum denn eigentlich
corona-gründe gibt es ja so nicht mehr
nein aber man hat während der Pandemie
gelernt Hauptversammlung lassen sich
auch online abhalten die Konzerne
benutzen gerne das Kostenargument online
Aktionärs treffen sind billiger aber
natürlich hat das noch einen anderen
Effekt für viele Aktionäre ist das
digitale Format völlig ungeeignet Fragen
müssen vorher eingereicht werden kein
direktes Frage Antwort Spiel mehr wenn
Deutsche Bank Chef Christian sewing zu
den Aktionären spricht dann schaut er
nicht wie früher in tausende Gesichter
sondern nur in eine Kamera so handhaben
ist inzwischen die meisten Konzerne mit
dem virtuellen Format haben Unternehmen
eine sehr leichte Möglichkeit auch
kritische Stimmen von sich wegzuhalten
weil einfach im virtuellen Format das
nicht so leicht zum Tragen kommt
virtuelle Hauptversammlungen zudem diese
Ballungen an Terminen heute Zufall sei
das nicht sagen Aktionärsvertreter ja
und können denn die und auch Aktionärs
Schütze so Interessen ausreichend
vertreten ja grundsätzlich schon
theoretisch geht das auch online doch 30
Aktionärsversammlungen an einem Tag das
ist das eigentliche Problem was soll das
die Frage steht im Raum passiert das
absichtlich denn klar ist für die
Aktionäre und Aktionärs Vertreter ist es
so maximal schwierig die Vorstände und
aufsichtsratsräte adäquat zu
kontrollieren allein schon aus Termin
Nöten heraus
vielen Dank
um den Missbrauch künstlicher
Intelligenz zu verhindern hat sich auch
der Entwickler der selbstlernenden
Textprogramm
für eine staatliche Regulierung
ausgesprochen bei einer Anhörung vor dem
US-Senat schlug open
Allmend eine Reihe von Sicherheitstests
vor kontrolliert durch eine neue
Regierungsbehörde
und hier sind die gewinnzahlen vom Lotto
am Mittwoch sie lauten ohne Gewähr 2 26
29 31 36 45 Superzahl 6 weitere
Gewinnzahlen auf Lotto zdf.de und im
zdf-text eine Meldung vom Radsport
Pascal ackermann hat auf der verregneten
11 etappe des Giro d'Italia in Tortona
den ersten deutschen tages-sieg erzielt
für den 29-Jährigen aus der Pfalz ist es
der erste Etappensieg seit 2019
schwere Unwetter haben auch in Teilen
von Bosnien-Herzegowina und Kroatien zu
Überschwemmungen und schweren Schäden
geführt in einigen Regionen wurde der
Notstand ausgerufen nach tagelang
heftigen Regenfällen steigen die
Flusspegel in Dalmatien weiter an
Hochwasser gefährdet Häuser und
Infrastruktur laut Wettervorhersage soll
der Regen dort in den kommenden Tagen
anhalten
und wir bleiben beim Thema Wetter und
blicken nach Italien in den letzten
Monaten hat das Land eine Trockenheit
und eine außergewöhnliche Dürre erlebt
die Folge extrem trockene Böden und die
wiederum führen nun zu einem anderen
Problem denn auf Trockenheit Folgen
aktuell extrem krasse Regenfälle Annette
hilsenbeck über sinnflutartige
Wolkenbrüche und Überschwemmungen die
sogar schon zu Todesopfern geführt haben
es ist ein Rettungseinsatz gegen die
Zeit gegen die Fluten um einen Mann aus
dem sütterern des Hauses zu holen
rasend schnell war der Fluss Savio
angestiegen in der Kleinstadt gesehener
nordwestlich von Rimini er überflutete
den halben Ort das Umland
in meinem 70-jährigen Leben habe ich den
Fluss noch nie so hoch gesehen
wir waren im Erdgeschoss dort dann ist
die Tragödie passiert wir haben nur das
mitgenommen was wir tragen konnten
über 1.000 Einsatzkräfte von Feuerwehr
und Polizei sind im Einsatz retten den
ganzen Tag Bewohnerinnen und Bewohner
aus ihren überfluteten Behausungen und
haben noch viel zu tun noch immer werden
Menschen vermisst
es gibt noch Menschen die aus
überfluteten Häusern geholt werden
müssen auch wenn sie nicht mehr direkt
in Gefahr sind ich komme gerade von
einem Erkundungsflug mit dem
Hubschrauber zurück und von oben kann
man das vom Hochwasser betroffene Gebiet
sehr gut sehen es ist sehr sehr
großflächig
[Musik]
alle 14 Flüsse in der Region waren über
die Ufer getreten betroffen auch die
Großstadt Bologna wo sogar die Piazza
Maggiore geflutet wurde
innerhalb eines Tages ging an manchen
Orten der Region ein Drittel des Jahres
Niederschlags herunter in den Monaten
zuvor hatte hier Trockenheit geherrscht
die Böden ausgedacht der zuständige
Minister spricht von einer neuen
Realität
nichts wird mehr sein wie es vorher war
was in diesen Stunden geschieht ist
Zeugnis für künftige lange dürre
Perioden und sehr kurze Perioden
heftiger Niederschläge
für die die bioboshita
intense wir müssen jetzt an ein
Wassersystem denken das Wasser speichert
am späten Nachmittag weichen die Fluten
in der kleinstadtcissaina zurück die
Menschen versuchen den Schlammmassen
Herr zu werden wer im Erdgeschoss lebt
kann vom Besitz nicht mehr viel retten
wir haben unsere Autos unser Hab und Gut
das wofür wir 20 Jahre lang geschuftet
haben innerhalb von fünf Minuten
verloren
es ist hart zu sehen sehr hässlich wie
ein Stich ins Herz
italienische Regierung hat nun
angekündigt in einer Sondersitzung
Hilfen für die hochwasserregion auf den
Weg zu bringen derweil gilt in der
Emilia Romania für die nächsten 24
Stunden weiterhin Alarmstufe Rot auch
das Formel 1 Rennen in Imola wurde
inzwischen abgesagt
hier folgt jetzt das Ausland Journal mit
einem Blick nach Griechenland wo am
Wochenende Parlamentswahlen stattfinden
und die Jugend frustriert überlegt das
Land zu verlassen
um 0 Uhr
mit unserem heute journal Updates
Morgen begrüßen Sie hier Christian
Sievers und Hanna Zimmermann machen sich
gut wo auch immer Sie sind auf
Wiedersehen
[Musik]
guten Abend da wölbt sich ein
Hochdruckgürtel vom Atlantik über
Großbritannien bis weit in den Osten so
einen Hochdruckgürtel erwarten wir zu
dieser Jahreszeit eigentlich über dem
Mittelmeer dort aber Sorgen Tiefs für
viel Regen und jetzt entwickelt sich
dann hier über Mallorca Sardinien und
Korsika gleich schon das nächste Tief
der weil tief chapu erstmal nach
Nordosten abzieht so drohen also weitere
Regenfälle bis Montag können durchaus am
zentralen Mittelmeer noch mal so 20 bis
80 Liter Regen pro Quadratmeter
zusammenkommen und in den westalben um
die 100 Meter pro Quadratmeter der Regen
ist das eine Thema die Temperaturen das
andere denn heute Nacht wird es noch mal
sehr kalt in Deutschland droht
verbreitet Bodenfrost empfindliche
Pflanzen sollten Sie also noch mal
schützen etwas milder bleibt es nur dort
wo es ein paar dichtere Wolkenfelder
gibt ganz im Norden und ganz im Süden
der Feiertag morgen wird sehr freundlich
Sonne und Wolken wechseln sich ab mal
geht es mir Wolken mal dominiert die
Sonne und der Winter Zug kommt nur
leicht aus nördlichen Richtung und so
bleibt es morgen noch kühl die
Temperaturen liegen bei 11 Grad am
Alpenrand und 18 Grad am Oberrhein das
aber steigert sich in den nächsten Tagen
aus den elf Grad am Alpenrand werden am
Sonntag 22 und hier südlich von Berlin
können sogar 29 Grad erreicht werden
Sonnenschein gibt es aber nicht überall
denn die Luft ist feucht und so
entwickeln sich kräftige Regenschauer
und Gewitter erst im Osten später dann
fast in ganz Deutschland guten Abend